- I need you to help me battle COVID-19
and it's with a step
that I'm almost certain
no one has talked to you about before.
This isn't clickbait.
There's been nearly 200,000
deaths here in the U.S.
and over a million across the globe.
Scientists have largely been stumped.
First, we say masks, then no masks;
then airborne, not airborne.
It's an absolute mess 'cause
we simply don't have info.
We don't have data.
It's a novel virus.
But that ends here because I have you.
All it takes is a few
minutes and a smartphone
and an app that I'm gonna
need you to download now.
I partnered up with Harvard
School of Public Health,
specifically Dr. Andrew Chan,
who gonna be talking with
throughout this video
to get you to download the
COVID Symptom Study app.
Using this app, we can track
what this virus is doing
across the United States.
We can catch hot pockets.
Not those Hot Pockets.
We can fight this virus.
We can find symptoms early.
We can see certain patterns.
In fact, it was this very app
that first identified the
loss of taste and smell
as a COVID-19 symptom.
I bet you thought it was me.
No, it wasn't. It was the app.
As if saving the world
from COVID-19 isn't enough,
I'm gonna sweeten the pot.
If you download this app,
and it gets to five million downloads,
and you comment on this video,
you're gonna be entered to
win 1 of 10 brand new iPhones.
We just got to get it to five million.
Five million. Five million. (laughs)
What would it mean to you
personally and also to Harvard
if this app gets to five million
downloads rather quickly?
- Yeah, so getting our app user base
up to five million would be huge
and we hope it doesn't stop there.
We want to continue to have
people download the app
because the more people
that download the app,
the more useful the
information is gonna be.
- How easy is this app to use?
- So this app is incredibly easy to use.
It really just requires
a couple of minutes
to download it to your phone
and then answer a few
very simple questions
about your health history,
and then provide some information
about how you're feeling.
- Once a user inputs information,
what's the things that they
get out of using the app?
- Once you share your information,
right away the app return
some information back
about how people around them are doing.
So it gives them, for example,
a percentage of people
that are potentially having
symptoms in their area
and also gives them some estimates
as to what COVID incidents might be like
in their local areas.
- Will the data collected
from this app be secure?
Is there any threat that it may be used
for nefarious purposes,
commercial purposes,
or is this solely for research?
- Absolutely, so we are
committed to using this data
in a secure and private way.
So we have no commercial interests.
We've been doing this purely
because we want to drive the science
and to drive the ability for
us to collect information
and analyze and share it
back with the community
and share it back with scientists.
- You may have heard on my channel
or in the media that people of color
are disproportionately
affected by COVID-19,
but I bet you never heard that doctors
and health professionals of color
are also disproportionately
getting affected by COVID-19
usually from the lack of
resources where they work.
How did we find that out?
This app.
You also have seen me
poopoo media's coverage
of these longterm health
effects of COVID-19,
like last time, I referenced this article
that said "COVID-19 in the brain.
Why you should be scared."
I don't like articles that
cause us to panic unnecessarily.
This study is looking into that too.
In fact, it's one of the biggest surprises
that Dr. Chan found when
looking at the data.
- I think we've been surprised
along with the rest of
the scientific community
that COVID-19 is often not
just a short-term infection.
That there are some people
that develop COVID-19
and do have some symptoms that
linger beyond a week or two.
But on the app, we've noticed
that about 10% of people report
that their symptoms after
infection have lingered
for as long as a month.
And I think that's been kind of a surprise
'cause that's not typical
of these sort of respiratory viruses.
- I'm actually gonna run
through the startup of this app
and create a new profile 'cause obviously,
I've already been reporting my symptoms,
or the lack thereof.
It's important to know you
can use this app for yourself,
you could also report on other's behalf.
So if you have a grandparent
or a parent who doesn't
know how to use an iPhone
or doesn't have the time,
you can help them out and
get more people reporting.
I'm gonna report based on
Dr. Mike's dad. (chuckles)
Okay, he's a person over 18.
We have adult consent.
Create profile.
Okay, are you a healthcare worker?
Yes, he is.
- [Announcer] 12 seconds later.
- Diet and lifestyle,
this section is what
really gets me excited
because it really allows
us to dig into the data
and see whether or not things
we do on an everyday basis,
how they affect catching the
virus, fairing with the virus,
recovering from the virus.
How do you feel physically right now?
See, this is an important part of the test
because depending on what you answer here,
it will then lead you down a
different type of questioning.
But he feels great. Thank God.
In just two minutes, it's done.
And all you have to do is
log in as often as you can
and just let it...
Even if you're well, you
just say, "I'm doing well."
Cool. It registers that.
But then if you're ever sick,
you log in and say,
"Hey, not feeling well.
Here are my symptoms."
And the great part is
it gives you feedback.
They tell you information right away
that they're learning, real-time.
Take a minute each day
and help fight the
outbreak in your community.
We have 4,164,824 people contributing.
That's amazing.
With economies and schools reopening,
we're gonna see upticks in
COVID-19 cases without a doubt.
But how are we to decide
when it's just a small uptick
or a true second wave?
This app will help us decide that.
If you wanna keep your
economy and your schools open,
participate in this app
so we don't panic unnecessarily.
If you can change one thing
from the U.S. response to
COVID-19, what would it be?
- To have really, a cohesive national plan
in terms of gathering data
to respond to the pandemic.
I think we recognize
now how important it is
to know what's happening
across the country
and to know what's happening in real time.
I really wanna thank
you for the opportunity
to share this with your audience,
and I think one other point I'd make
is that one of the things
we've been so impressed by
is that your program, and
I think your audience,
really wants the truth
and wants hard facts and
information about COVID-19.
If you are willing to share
a little bit information
and involve your family and friends,
we'll be able to have facts and have data
that can really get at the truth.
And that's ultimately what
we need to protect ourselves
and protect our community
and respond as a country,
no matter where we live, what
walk of life we come from,
what our background is.
I think we want to hear from you.
And this is, I think, an easy way for us
to let your voice be heard.
- I know I'm coming off
as extremely excited,
but it's because I desperately want you
to participate and download this app.
We've largely felt powerless
and confused with this virus
because there's so much to learn about it
in such a short period of time,
and we in the scientific community
are struggling getting research done.
You can help us with that.
All you have to do is download this app,
spend a couple of minutes,
take a break from TikTok,
I know you like scrolling,
I know you like the dancing,
but this app can legitimately save lives.
and you could win an
iPhone, 1 of 10 iPhones.
This app gets to five million downloads,
and your common is down below?
You're officially in the running, folks.
Download the app, link's below.
Click here for doctor pranking
video that's really funny.
You're gonna see some of my
doctors question my sanity
and medical knowledge.
Or check out this latest memes video
that you may have missed.
In fact, I'm putting a
couple of here for you.
And as always, stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat music)